from shape-shifting Gods to lightning
shooting dragons it wouldn't be The
Witcher without some interdimensional
monsters on that count blood origin
doesn't disappoint
played by Goodwill Hunting star mini
driver shanaki doesn't give us many
Clues regarding her nature her first
action is to save yaskir on a
battlefield after freezing the soldiers
in time shanaki later emerges from the
Shadows looking like yaskir himself only
to switch to a monstrous appearance and
finally take the form of an elf to calm
The Bard she denies being a Doppler or a
shapeshifter but she clearly has very
similar abilities at the same time
shanaki seems to have some level of
control over time and as driver said on
Twitter space the actress sees her
character as a collector of stories
someone who retrieves long Forgotten
Tales and brings them back to musicians
to share with people when they need them
the most the elves need a story lost to
time or one of the few who overcame the
many the story of the Seven telling ask
here the story behind the conjunction of
the Spheres and the creation of the
first Witcher may not seem to have a
clear purpose unless we connect it to
the events that take place in season 2
of The Witcher during this time several
monoliths are used to open portals to
other worlds this frequently leads to
several monsters Crossing into the
continent and wreaking havoc their
arrival is expected to bring even more
chaos to this world after all the first
conjunction of the Spheres leads to the
end of Elven rule as well as to the
creation of the now famous monster
hunters with such desperate times
waiting for them in the future the
different inhabitants of the continent
may need to remember how this all began
in the first place and learned that they
should remain hopeful regardless of the
chaos in that sense yaskir's new song
may just become the most powerful weapon
at their disposal most monsters in The
Witcher are based on real folklore the
Doppler for example is a variation of a
mythological creature from Finland and
Ireland the Gin on the other hand comes
from ancient Middle Eastern folklore
nevertheless some creatures have a much
simpler nature monsters like the
arachnomorph and Andrea look like
overgrown spiders and scorpions and
something very similar happens with the
giant centipede a creature that is
referred to in the books the giant
centipede makes an appearance in season
two of The Witcher although with drastic
changes to its design and it's a common
enemy in The Witcher 3 wild Hunt in The
Witcher blood origin the heroes
encounter their first Monster when
opening a portal to approach the city of
zentreya they enter a new world not very
different from their own except for its
inclusion of a beautiful flower that
ends up being the lure of a giant white
centipede which proceeds to hunt them
they managed to escape by jumping back
to the world and closing the portal
while the creature is still crossing the
pale Widow is probably one of the few
monsters in blood origin that's easily
identifiable as it's part of the
beastery of The Witcher 3 wild Hunt
despite its relatively simple nature
however it ends up becoming an important
resource for the heroes increasing their
chances of Victory and changing one of
them forever probably the most
intriguing creature in the miniseries
the monster brought by Balor from
another world is very difficult to
classify it has insect-like legs and
wings can fly has the shape of a dragon
and shoots lightning capable of turning
people into mist from its three
Arrowhead shaped Tales it's this ability
that allows Balor to execute the king
and the heads of most Warrior Clans
almost instantly Paving the way for his
allies to take over the empire
in that moment the Elven world had
changed forever a thousand years of
monarchies kingdoms and clans were
erased as a result both the empress and
her soldiers adopt the three Arrowhead
shaped tales as their coat of arms and
wear the symbol on their armor however
the confidence in their capacity to
control anything on the other side of
the portals proves to be their greatest
weakness baller's monster eventually
Falls and becomes the first creature
slain by a Witcher but having tasted the
power of chaos magic Balor sacrifices
fenrik the only person he cares about to
acquire an immense amount of power when
he returns to the Palace though he tests
his new abilities on syndril and zakari
who use their power to redirect the
energy to the monolith destroying it in
the process tragically rather than solve
their problems this causes multiple
portals to open an event known in the
books as the conjunction of the Spheres
leading to the arrival of both humans
and monsters to the continent this is
the end of the empress's delusions of
conquering other worlds and eventually
the destruction of Elven civilization
the process of creating Witcher is
complex and intensely painful prospects
go through a series of chemical
treatments that leave them in fertile
and relatively emotionless on the plus
side the process also grants them
enhanced sight resistance to poisons and
illnesses increased agility and strength
and the ability to wield a small but
useful amount of magic some of these
changes may seem random but one of the
things blood origin makes clear is how
necessary some of these features are
when creating the perfect monster Slayer
finding themselves close to the
empress's castle but with no way in Phil
turns to a dangerous ritual that uses
potions and spells to fuse his body with
a slain monster the painful process
almost kills him but also gives him
enormous strength as well as a high
level of aggressiveness and a deep
desire to hunt when he's finally brought
to the castle he loses control after
seeing Ayla being hurt by baller's
creature this puts him in a sort of
Berserker state where his skin turns
gray and his muscle mass grows to
monstrous levels he uses this strength
to slay the creature but he loses
control of his emotions and ends up
attacking his friends who are forced to
kill him
[Music]